ما نعمل اللي صار فينا منام
وصلت على الدرجه تحت قلبت فينا البنايه
انا من هون من تحت السقف تحتي ضليت كم
ساعه عيط عيط عيط بعدين سكتت اشهدت اخر
نفس واحد لحتى سمعني بس انا شايفه جوزي
تحت السقف وفي اولاد جسس فوقي
في شو اسمه
في اولاد كثير فوقي كانوا
بعدين شو اسمه
جابولي ابني قالوا لي عايش تروح انت ضللي
واحد تروح انت
النادي اخواته
ادم راح ادوس بعد صلاه
اكثر من هيك يا عمي شو بده يصير
[تصفيق]
يلا روحي يلا يلا وصلنا
زلزال سوريا وتركيا المدمر احد اعنف
الزلازل في العالم واشدها فتكا منذ اكثر
من عقد
الكارثه وقعت فجر الاثنين السادس من
فبراير زلزال بقوه سبع درجات فاصله ثمانيه
ضرب مساحات شاسعه من جنوب تركيا وشمال
سوريا تسبب بصدع يمتد طوله لما يزيد على
مئه كيلو متر بين الصفيحه الاناضليه
والصفيحه العربيه مركزه كان على بعد 26
كيلومترا تقريبا شرقيه مدينه نورداي
التركيه
[موسيقى]
جميع سكان سوريا وتركيا شعروا بالزلزال
حتى الدول المجاوره لكن اثره المدمر تمركز
في شمال غربي سوريا وتحديدا في محافظات
حلب وحماه واللاذقيه وطرطوس وادلب اما في
تركيا فضرب الزلزال بعنف 10 ولايات وحولها
لمناطق منكوبه
[موسيقى]
بعد 11 دقيقه من الزلزال الاول تعرضت
المنطقه لهزه ارتداديه بلغت قوتها ست
درجات فاصله سبعه
وبعد ساعات وقع زلزال بقوه سبع درجات ونصف
الدرجه تلته هزه اخرى بقوه ست درجات في
فتره ما بعد الظهر
[موسيقى]
حصيله الزلزال العنيف لم تتوقف عن
الارتفاع بين قتلى وجرحه ومفقودين ومشردين
تجاوزت عشرات الالاف في كلا البلدين عدا
عن الاف المنازل والمباني المدمره
منظمه الصحه العالميه قدرت ان يبلغ 23
مليونا عدد المتضررين بالزلزال بينهم نحو
خمسه ملايين من الاكثر ضعفا
وفيما تتلاشى امال العثور على ناجين تحت
الانقاض ووسط طقس صقيعي شديد البروده
تنهمل فرق الاغاثه في البلدين المنكوبين
في عمليات البحث والانقاذ في حين بدات
قوافل المساعدات الدوليه الوصول الى
المناطق المنكوبه ملوك الشيخ العربيه
ونحن مستمرون معكم في هذه التغطيه على
شاشه العربيه لتداعيات الزلزال الذي ضرب
جنوب تركيا وشمال سوريا ورغم مشاهد الدمار
الشديده خلال الساعات القليله الماضيه
كانت هناك بعض الاخبار الايجابيه تم انقاذ
طفلين في منطقه ملاطيا جنوب غرب تركيا
وهناك بعض المؤشرات على ان هناك بعض
الاحياء ربما تحت هذا الركام في احد
المباني في مدينه ملاطيا التي تقع في جنوب
غرب
تركيا ايضا هناك مساعدات دخلت هذا هو
اليوم الاول التي تنجح فيه مساعدات امميه
الى الدخول الى الشمال السوري بعد اعلان
الامين العام للامم المتحده انطونيو
بوتيرج انه تم ارسال مساعدات دخلت عبر
معبر باب الهوى تضم ست شاحناتان بها
مساعدات مواد تغذيه وتدفئه ايضا مراسل
العربيه ايضا افاد انه دخلت مساعدات الى
الشمال السوريه ايضا
عبر معبر باب الهوى مساعدات من اسبانيا
هذه فيما يتعلق بالمساعدات التي وصلت الى
الشمال السوري ايضا المملكه العربيه
السعوديه اعلنت عن انطلاق الجسر الجوي
لاغاثه المتضررين في سوريا وتركيا
وهناك صور لهذه الشاحنات التي ستتحرك من
مطار الملك خالد الدولي بالرياض حيث ستضم
كما تشاهدون على الهواء
معده وشاحنات
بها فرق من الدفاع المدني السعودي يتم
شحنها عبر طائره خاصه استعدادا لانطلاقها
بعد ساعات قليله في بدايه هذا الليل الى
مطار اضنه التركي هذه المساعدات التي امر
بها العاهل السعودي الملك سلمان وولي
العهد الامير محمد بن سلمان بلغ حجم
التبرعات للمتضررين حتى هذه اللحظه في
اطار التبرعات السعوديه اكثر من ثمانين
مليون ريال
المتحدث الرسمي للدفاع المدني السعودي
محمد الحمادي اكد ان فرق الانقاذ والتجهيز
تعملوا حاليا على التجهيز والانتقال الى
مدينه اضنه التركيه من اجل تقديم العمل
والمسانده بعد توجيهات من العاهل السعوديه
الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز
تنفيذا لتوجيهات مولاي خادم الحرمين
الشريفين وسموه سيدي ولي العهد رئيس مجلس
الوزراء وبمتابعه مثل الداخليه يعمل فريق
البحث والانقاذ السعودي الان على اعمال
التجهيز وشحن الاليات والمعدات الفنيه
اللازمه لانتقال فريق البحث من القائد
السعودي خلال الساعات القادمه الى مطار
اضنه لتقديم الدعم والمسانده في اعمال
البحث والانقاذ من قبل فريق البحث القادم
السعودي والذي يضم طواقم انقاذ ومختصين في
اعمال البحث والانقاذ فنيين وايضا مهندسين
وكذلك اطباء فريق مصنف دوليا ومكتمل من
كافه التجهيزات
وكافه ما يتطلبه الموقف والبد في اعمال
البحث والانقاذ فور الوصول الى مطار اضنه
وصور حصريه للعربيه اظهرت استمرار عمليات
البحث والانقاذ في مدينتي حارم وسلقين في
ريف ادلب واللتين تعرضت لضمار كبير سكان
المدينتين وكذلك المتطوعين يستخدمون كل
الوسائل المتاحه في محاوله باتت خجوله في
هذه اللحظات لانقاذ عالقنا تحت الانقاض
بعد مرور ساعات طويله نحن في اليوم الرابع
لهذا الزلزال
بايديهم وارجلهم وكل ما تيسر من معدات
يقاتل السوريون في احدى معاركهم الكثيره
سكان ومتطوعون يسابقون الزمن في مدينتي
حارم وسلقين اكثر المدن المتضرره من
الزلزال في ادلب
عمليات الحفر والانقاذ مستمره فيما وقعت
على عاتق الكثيرين المهمه الاثقل وهي
انتشال الجثث ومرافقتها سواء لتسليمها لمن
بقي من العائله او للمشافي قبل الدفن
الغصه تكبر حين رؤيه الدمار من اعلى رغم
قساوه المشهد على الارض مبان سويت بالتراب
واخرى باتت عاريه لا تسترها نافذه او باب
او حائط لكن حتى تلك يخشى ان تحوي في احدى
زواياها شخصا عاجزا عن النزول حيده
الزلزال فعليق في برد دون كسوه
عواصف شتاء وثلوج ونوبات بحث متواصله
انهكتهم حينا لكنها لم توقف مسعاهم
عالقونا قد يكونون بانتظارهم منذ وقت طويل
وملت اجسادهم الانتظار
ونستمر معكم في متابعه داعيات هذا الزلزال
الذي ضرب جنوب تركيا وشمال سوريا ونركز
الان على الجانب الخاص بشمال سوريا من
ادلب ينضموا الينا عبر اسقيب الصحفي مسلم
السيد عيسى مرحبا بك مسلم يعني ضعنا في
اخر التطورات فيما يتعلق بوصول مساعدات
كانت هناك بارقه امل اليوم بدخول مساعدات
امميه وايضا مساعدات من اسبانيا الصوره
لديك
[موسيقى]
نعم مساء الخير حقيقه هذا يعني هاي الامل
هذه لم تتحقق حتى هذه اللحظه لا تزال
معلقه وكيف ما يحصل في المعابر الحدوديه
نؤكد عدم دخول اي قافله انسانيه مخصصه
لكارثه الزلازل ما دخله فقط القافله
الامميه الدوريه على الشق الاخر قبل قليل
دخل ثاني فريق مخصص لانقاذ والكوارث وهو
فريق اسباني مؤلف من تقريبا خمسه عشر مسعف
ومتخصص في الكوارث دخل الى الجانب السوري
عبر معبر باب الهوى وتوجه مع فرقه الدفاع
المدني الى المناطق التي تشهد حتى هذه
اللحظه
رفع انقاذ هل في تماما بعض
العاجله التي تم انشائها للناجين من تحت
الانقاذ ووضعت تماما بالقرب من منطقه التي
يتم فيها اخلاء ورفع الانقاذ الاهالي فضلت
عدم الابتعاد عن مناطقها ومنازلها تمسكا
باي امل
تفضل مسلم نعم هذه الخيار هذه الخيام توجد
فيها الاهالي الذين ان نجوا من تحت
الانقاض تم انشاؤها من قبل المنظمات
المحليه فقط بشكل عاجل لكنها تستقل لكل
مقومات
الحياه الطارئه
طيب مسالم الى اي مدى يمكن ان تساهم
المساعدات الامميه الامين العام كان يتحدث
عن ست شاحنات تضم مواد تغذيه وادويه
وتدفئه هل وصلت هل استطاع البعض الاستفاده
منها في هذه المناطق في ادلب وحلب
حتى هذه اللحظه اؤكد انه لم تدخل ايه
مساعدات متعلقه بالكارثه الزلزال الذي حدث
قبل اربعه ايام هنا في الشمال الغربي
لسوريا من المتوقع ان تبدا هذه القوافل
الدخول عبر حدوثيه سواء معبر باب الهوى او
معفر الارض اعلنت عنه الجانبين السوري
وتركيا لكن حتى هذه اللحظه لم تدخل ايه
مساعده
كل المساعدات المحليه
عبر المزيد عن المصادر الاعلاميه تشير
لدخول مساعدات الامم المتحده وانها عبرت
بالفعل معبر باب الهوى
الصوت يتقطع اذا كان مسلم يمكن ان تتحرك
الى مكان اعلى ان الصوت والاتصالات صعبه
ولكن نريد ان نسمعك بشكل جيد تفضل
مسلم
هل نعم تفضل
هناك توضيح مهم القافله التي دخلت هي من
المساعدات الامميه للامم المتحده من www
تدخل من قبل هذه الازمه قبل منذ سنوات
وحتى اللحظه بشكل دوري ليست مخصصه
للكارثه كارثه الزلزال الذي ضرب شمال
وشمال غرب سوريا هذه القافله هي تدخل بشكل
دوري كل 15 يوم تدخل تقريبا 15 الى 17
شاحنه من الامم المتحده توزع على المؤسسات
المحليه بما يخص المساعدات المخصصه للقاده
الزلزال لم تدخل حتى اللحظه ايه مساعدات
سواء امميه او عربيه او دوليه يتم التجهيز
على الطرف التركي ربما لا ندري للكثير من
الشاحنات والقوافل الاغاثيه لكنها
سؤال مسلم هل تم اصلاح الطريق الى معبر
باب الهوى لان كان هذا عائقا في الايام
الماضيه لدخول المساعدات كان الجميع يقول
ان المعبر مفتوح ولكن المشكله في ان
الطريق الذي يمكن العبور منه لادخال هذه
المساعدات كان يعاني من صعوبات شديده
هذا هو من الجانب التركي يعاني الاستراد
المواصل الى باب الهوى من تهدمات وغيرها
فعلا كانت عائق حتى هذه اللحظه تم استبدال
بطريق مجاور لهذا الطريق لعمر الشاحنات
وهي الشاحنات التي دخلت اليوم للمساعدات
الامميه لكن ليست مخصصه للكوارث كما ذكرت
هي تدخل بشكل دوري وايضا تعبر من هنا ايضا
الى مناطق النظام وغيرها
الجدير بالذكر ان المساعدات المحليه هنا
كادت وبدات تنفذ بشكل مباشر نقطه مهمه جدا
او التوضيحها في هذا السياق ان المساعدات
المحليه المنظمات المحليه هنا قبل تقريبا
يوم او اكثر
من حدوث الزلزال افرغت كامل مستودعاتها
الاضافيه بما تحويها نتيجه الازمه التي
ضربت المنطقه هنا بعد الثلوج والفيضانات
التي ضربت اكثر من
مخيم في شمال غرب سوريا وبالتالي كانت
مستودعات هذه المنظمات فارغه لا تمتلك ايه
امكانيات انسانيه واضافيه على
نعم حتى هناك اسعاف تصل الى هذه المنطقه
لكن مع الاسف اخر من تم انقاذه هنا من هذه
النقطه في مدينه حارم هو في الساعه
الرابعه من فجر هذا اليوم اي قبل اكثر من
20 ساعه انقذ رجل وامراه وطفل وما بعدها
كل ما تم انقذهم وانتشالهم هم جثث لضحايا
اضيفوا الى الضحايا الذين اليوم تم انقاذ
رجل وامراه وطفل في مدينه ادلب ولكن عدد
من تم انتشالهم بعد ذلك كانوا اموات
انت كنت تتحدث في نقطه مهمه قبل هذا الامر
وهي مساله الحج الشديده للمساعدات
والاغاثه لان الوضع الانساني صعب للغايه
تم الاعتماد على رصيد الجمعيات التي كانت
موجوده بالفعل قبل هذه الكارثه في الشمال
السوري ولكن ولكن بدا مخزون هذه المنظمات
والهيئات في النفاذ هل هناك اي معلومات عن
اتصالات تتم لفتح معبر الراعي معبر السلام
هذه معابر وشرايين ايضا يمكن الاعتماد
عليها في هذا التوقيت الحرج هل تمت انباء
عن هذا الامر
نعم في هذا السياق المعابر الحدوديه هي
ثلاثه التي تم الاعلان عن جاهزيتها لدخول
المساعدات انا اتحدث عن الطرف السوري هي
جاهزه وايضا انا شاهدت الكثير من المنظمات
الانسانيه المحليه سائله سوري والعمال
بانتظار اي شحنات تتصل متاخره
الى الشاحنات وبدا توزيعها على
الصوت يتقطع مسلم لا نسمعك بشكل جيد وهذا
امر طبعا متوقع من انقطاع الصوت نتيجه ضعف
الاتصالات في هذه المنطقه
سنبقى ايضا في متابعه هذه الصور التي
تاتينا ايضا من مدينه الدانه في ريفي ادلب
الصحفي محمد الاشقر سيتابع معنا وينقل لنا
الوضع من هناك مرحبا بك محمد
نعم مرحبا بك كيف تبدو الاوضاع لديك هل
هناك رصيد يكفي من المساعدات ماذا عن
عمليات الانقاذ ماذا عن الضحايا هل هناك
امل في وجود بعض الناجين لديك من خلال
اعمال الفرق الموجوده من منظمات المجتمع
المدني
نعم يعني في الحقيقه منذ الصباح الباكر
ونحن في مدينه جندير الشريف
حلب هذه المدينه التي
نالت ما نالته من نصيبها من الدمار من عدد
الضحايا الذين لا يزول لا يزالون الى حد
هذه اللحظه تحت الانقاذ منذ منذ اربعه
ايام منذ بدء هذه الكارثه هو فرق الدفاع
المدني وفرق الانقاذ والمدنيين يحاولون
انتشار الضحايا من تحت
الانقاض يعني في الحقيقه منذ الصباح
الباكر عشرات الجثامين
تمكنت
فرق الدفاع المدني من اخراجها من تحت
الانقاب من مدينه جنديرس فقط وتحديدا من
حي سوق الهال وشارع الصناع ايضا في هذه
المدينه عشرات
الوفيات اليوم
وبالتالي من الزلزال كانت قوه الزلزال
كبيره فيها
نعم نعم نحن نتحدث عن عشرات الضحايا فقط
الذين تم اخراجهم اليوم بالنسبه لان عجين
اليوم لم تسجل اي حاله
نجاه لاي احد تم انقاذه من تحت الالقاب
كما ذكرت لك جميع من تم اخراجهم كانوا
متوفين نتيجه هذه الكارثه طبعا هذه
الكارثه انعكست سلبا على الوضع الانساني
نتيجه النزوح من هذه المدينه نتيجه اللجوء
الى اماكن متفرقه في ريفي حلب ريف حلب
الشمالي وريف ادلب ايضا
الاهالي والمهجرين اساسا الى مدينه جنديرس
لجاوا الى مناطق اخرى الى مراكز ايواء
انشاتها الفرق التطوعيه والمنظمات
الانسانيه الموجوده اصلا في في
المنطقه في منطقه شمال غرب سوريا طبعا هذه
العائلات ه
بحاجه ماسه للمساعدات الانسانيه هم بحاجه
لمحمد اي مساعدات
بشكل واضح ان هناك شاحنات ست شاحنات دخلت
عبر معبر باب الهوى هل وصلت الى ادلب
او لم تتاكد ايه انباء عن دخول اي مساعدات
باتجاه شمال غرب سوريا وان هذه الست
شاحنات هي موجوده اساسا قبل حادثه الزلزال
واليوم قد تم السماح بعبورها واضح ان هناك
حاله من اللبس الشديد في هذا الامر فهم من
تصريحات الامين العام للامم المتحده
انطونيو بوتيريوس ان هذه المساعدات او
المساعدات تدخل عبر معبر باب الهوى لضحايا
هذا الزلزال ولكن المراسلين والصحفيين على
ارض يقولون ان بعض المنظمات تقول ان هذه
المساعدات كانت مدرجه اساسا على جدول
المساعدات الروتينيه للشعب السوري في هذه
المنطقه على حال محمد انت تتحدث عن ان
الحديث عن ناجين اصبح امر صعب في هذه
المناطق في ريف ادلب
نعم يعني في مناطق حدوث الكارثه وهي اكثر
من 56 قريه هو بلده ومدينه اليوم بعد كل
هذه الساعات بعد اربعه ايام من حدوث هذه
الكارثه اصبح من الصعب الحديث عن ناجين
تحت الانقاض طبعا هذا الحديث بعد ان
تحدثنا وسالنا احد الخبراء بعمليات
الانقاذ وقال ان الامر اصبح قد بات معجزه
وذلك لعوامل هي حتى ان وجد احد حي تحت
الانقاض فيتعرض لعمليه الاختناق نتيجه
المده الطويله ان لم يتعرض لعمليه
الاختناق
يتوفى نتيجه حاجه جسده للماء الامر بحسب
ما وصفه هو بحاجه معجزه لخروج احد من تحت
انقاذ بعد كل هذه كيف يمكن تقييم اعمال
الانقاذ في المساحه الجغرافيه التي حدث
فيها الزلزال في شمال سوريا في المناطق
الخاضعه للمعارضه كيف يتم تقييم اعمال
الانقاذ هل هي في مستوى جيد متوسط منخفض
نعم طبعا بالنسبه
لعمليات الانقاذ فرق الانقاذ تابعه للدفاع
الوطني تعمل باعلى من طاقاتها اساسا
والمدنيون ايضا يعملون باعلى من طاقاتهم
الفرق التطوعيه الشبابيه التي اسست
للتعامل مع هذه الكارثه تعمل باعلى من
طاقاتها العامل
الذي اثر على على ازدياد عدد الوفيات وقله
عدد الناجين من تحت الانقاذ هو عدم توفر
المعدات والاجهزه
والاليات اللازمه والمجهزه للتعامل مع مثل
هذه الكوارث نحن نلاحظ ان جميع الفرق التي
تعمل على انتشال الضحايا من تحت الانقاب
تعمل الادوات بدائيه بادوات يدويه
نشاهد شاهدنا في اغلب المواقع ان
المدنيين هم من يقومون بالحفر بايديهم في
الركام للبحث عن عن زويهم عن احبابهم تحت
الانقاذ هذا الامر ادى الى تاخر عمليات
الانقاذ هو كم وهو الامر ايضا الذي ادى
الى ارتفاع اعداد الوفيات وقله فرص
الناجين الخارجي من تحت الارض طيب ابقى
معي محمد سنتابع ايضا التطورات في شمال
السوري وسنبقى في ادلب ايضا لمتابعه
التطورات باعتبار ان ادلب وحلب من المناطق
التي تضررت بشده والتي كانت تعيش اساسا
وضع انساني صعب نتيجه
الحرب وهي المناطق التي تسيطر عليها
المعارضه السوريه ينضم الينا مسلم السيد
عيسى الصحفي من جديد مرحبا بك مسلم كان
الزميل محمد الاش يتحدث عن انه يتم اللجوء
الى ادوات بدائيه الى جهود تطوعيه من
الاهالي حتى ان بعض الاهالي يقوم بعمليه
الحفر بنفسه كيف يبدو او كيف تبدو الصوره
فيما يتعلق
بالمعابر الاخرى الطرق الاخرى هل من اي
سبيل او اي انباء او اتصالات لفتح هذه
المعابر لدعم الوضع الانساني الصعب لديكم
نعم كنت اتحدث في نفس هذا السياق تواصلت
مع المنظمات المحليه هنا التي تعمل كشركاء
للمنظمات الدوليه وايضا العربيه في عموم
المناطق العربيه قالوا انهم تلقوا اتصالات
ووعود بان الشاحنات والقوافل الاغاثيه
بكميات محدده يعني تم الاتفاق عليها بين
الاطراف الانسانيه بدات بالتجهيز على
الطرف التركي اعتقد ان هذه هذا التاخير
الذي حصل بسبب ان الطرقات في الجانب
التركي كانت مدمره غير صالحه ابدا لعبور
هذه الشاحنات اليوم الشاحنات التي دخلت
التابعه للامم المتحده سلكت طرقا مختلفه
عن الطريق الرئيسي لباب الهوى استراد باب
الهوى حتى استطاعت الدخول لكنها مع الاسف
كانت غير مجهزه او غير كانت يعني غير
مخصصه لهذه الكارثه كما ذكرت هي قوافل
دوريه من المتوقع ان تدخل اول قافله خلاله
الليل او فجر هذا اليوم التالي وربما خلال
غدا صباحا كل التح الانسانيه من الطرف
سواء السوري او التركي هي جاهزه لاستقبال
هذه الشحنات شاهدنا في المعبر السوري سواء
باب الهوى او باب السلامه او معبر الراعي
على الطرف التركي شاحنات فارغه من الطرف
السوري تنتظر مع المتطوعين والعمال لوصول
اي شحنات اضافيه لنقلها مباشره الى
الاستخدام هذه المعابر لدخول المساعدات
وهذا قد يعد مؤشر جيد
بالطبع المؤشرات على الارض تتحدث ربما عن
هذه الاتفاقيات لم يتم الاعلان او الاشهار
عن اي اتفاقيه لكن الجانب التركي اعلن عن
افتتاح هذه المعابر وايضا الجانب السوري
عبر انه جاهز لاستقبال اي من الشحنات سواء
عبر كل هذه المعابر الثلاثه المنتشره على
طول حدود السوريه التركيه شمال محافظه
ادلب وايضا شمال محافظه حلب وعلى شق الاخر
بما يخص المنظمات سواء الانسانيه المحليه
او خارج الحدود من المنظمات الدوليه او
العربيه هناك اتصالات تجري بين هذه
الاطراف لانها سابقا ايضا تعمل كشراكات مع
المؤسسات الموجوده على الارض كمثال يعني
كل المنظمات العربيه والمنظمات الدوليه
لديها شركاء محليين على الارض يتواصلون
بشكل مباشر يحددون الاحتياجات ويعملون على
التنسيق لاستقبال هذه الشحنات من المتوقع
ان يصمد هذا المخزون الى ان تصل المساعدات
الجديده
وهذا فعلا يعني ما نتحدث عنه بشكل دائم
وما يحدث على ارض الواقع مستودعات
المنظمات الانسانيه هنا المحليه فارغه
تماما اعتقد ان كل ما رايناه وشاهدناه
اليوم من المساعدات التي قدمت هي تم
شرائها بشكل جديد من اخر مخزون مالي
للمنظمات تم شرائها من الوسط من الاسواق
المحليه هنا وايضا النقطه الثانيه مجموعه
التبرعات التي العينيه التي تم جمعها في
المساجد في الساحات العامه من الاهالي
المتواجدين في المناطق التي لم تتضرر
والمناطق الامنه شاهدنا في مركز المدن
الامنه نداءات بمكبرات الصوت في المساجد
على كل الناس الذين لم يتضرروا ولديهم بعض
الاشياء التي يمكن ان يتبرعوا بها ان
يقدموا عليها معكم سنبقى معكم في متابعه
هذه الاوضاع الانسانيه وفي متابعه الجهود
المبذوله ايضا لتخفيف هذه المعاناه على
الشمال السوري الشكر مسلم السيد عيسى
الصحفي من ادلب على متابعته معنا وايضا من
ريف ادلب الصحفيه محمد الاشقر شكرا لكما
تحت الركام مثل
الشباب هاي الموجوده كلياتها
تتساعدت ولكن بالاياديش يعني نحتاج لكادرا
اكبر ما حدا قصر بس هاي امكانيات الشعب
الموجود الله يكون بالعون
جايين تطوع هون
العالم ماسات الله اكبر سنه 48 ساعه
حجم الكارثه كبير وفي رقمها تقوم بالبحث
الى الان في قريه بثانيه على اخراج
العالقين تحت الانقاض
الساعه 4:12 دقيقه بلشت الهزه يا دوب
نزلنا من البنايه وصارت الحياطين تهدم
علينا ويدوب نفذنا بسابع والناس
ونزلنا جوه على البستان تمينا من الساعه
اربعه
للوجه للصبح الساعه تسعه واحنا تحت المطر
وحاليا جيني على المخيم
والله قضينا الليله عند جيراننا بالخيام
بالخيام وغطسنا بالوحل للركاكيب غطشنا
يعني
ذبحنا البرد انا والله طالعوني من جوه
الانقاذ
ومفيقتني عيلتي البنايه دعت هز شلت
الويلات
راحت برا شي الحيطان كلها اتفشتني رجعتني
على
الغرفه عيلتي نزلت على الدرج هبط عليها
بيت الدرج
ولادي اثنيناتهم بدايه
يعني
صار الزلزال نحنا باركين في البيت ليه ما
حسيتو الا الارض صارت دقيت بالاولاد
وصارنا نرقد عند اللي رقدنا صارت ترج
الارض في زياده وطلعنا والله يعني لله
الامر والتدبير طلعنا عراه يعني والله
سترنا اي والله بغمد عنه لاني صار بهالليل
[موسيقى]
القصص والصور الانسانيه مؤلمه بالطبع لكن
ابطال هذه اللحظات هم رجال الانقاذ مهمات
عده القيت على كاهلهم منذ حلول الكارثه
على جنوب تركيا وشمال سوريا فبين عمليات
البحث والانقاذ محادثات تريح قلب منتظر او
تهون عليه المصيبه
ارهاق بدا يظهر على وجوههم نوبات بحث
متواصله انهكتهم فعلا لكن الاشد ارهاقا
تعاملهم مع العالقين تحت الركام ومن
ينتظرهم في الخارج
ثلاثه ايام من عمليه البحث كانت مهمات
عمال الانقاذ خلالها كثيره ولم تقتصر فقط
على الحفر سواء بالايدي او المعدات
هؤلاء كانوا حضنا لامهات واباء اثقلهم هم
الفقد وتحولوا كتفا تكئ عليها الجميع عند
وقوع الفاجعه الله يصبر
دخيلك
قل لا اله الا الله
طمانه المنتظرين خارج المباني المدمره شيء
لكن ملاقاه اطفال لفهم الرعب لساعات وحتى
ايام شيء اخر
تكبير في البدايه نعم اي بعد سماع النفس
ورؤيه وجوه تتكلم تلهي دعابه او اي كلمه
قد تزيح عن مسرح طفولتهم مشاهد خوف وذعر
ولو للحظه كما يزاح الغبار المتراكم على
اجسادهم
ما شاء الله ما شاء الله
بعد الانقاذ تبدا معاناه البحث عما يطفئ
اجساد الناجين وماواه يقيهم البرد لم يس
معني كابوس الماضي يلاحق عمال الانقاذ
السوريين صور حرب ارادوا مسحها من ذاكرتهم
بفعل تقدم السنين لكنها اليوم عادت وبشكل
اقصى
[موسيقى]
يلا براءه
يلا يلا
يا شباب
يا الله
[موسيقى]
ونذهب الى قهرمان مرعش ينضم الينا غسان
ابو لوز وموفد العربيه مرحبا بك غسان ضعنا
في الصوره غسان حول مجهود الانقاذ وربما
اسالك غسان لماذا اختفى الحديث عن مساله
اعداد النجين كنا في اليوم الاول والثاني
نطرح هذا السؤال هل بمرور الوقت اصبح هذا
السؤال بلا معنى
يعني هو وقت صعب جدا رشا عندما تتحدثين عن
اربعه ايام تحت الانقاض فهو وقت صعب جدا
بالفعل لكن لحتى اللحظه يتم الاعلان عن
اخراج ناجين من تحت الانقاذ يعني انا حيث
اقف قبل نصف ساعه تقريبا قال ابلغنا احد
عناصر الانقاذ انهم
انقذوا سيده في الاربعينيات من العمر
تمكنوا من انقاذها لكن هنا في هذا المنزل
رشا اود الاشاره فقط بان هذا المنزل عمال
الانقاذ قالوا لنا بانهم بان هناك خمس
اشخاص داخل هذا المبنى وهم على قيد الحياه
وايضا من بين هؤلاء الاشخاص اطفال لكن لا
نعلم كم عددهم بالتحديد وهم يقولون بان في
هذه النقطه تحديدا موجودين تحديدا
نعم رصدوا الاصوات هم يعملون في هذا
المبنى منذ ساعات الصباح وهم يعني بحسب
رصدهم الاصوات تاكدوا بان هناك خمس اشخاص
موجودين تحت موجودين يعني بين هذه الانقاض
وقالوا لنا بان بينهم اطفال لكن لا نعرف
عدد الاطفال والان توقفت الاليات الثقيله
كانت تعمل قبل قليل توقفت وتدخلت العناصر
البشريه وهم يستخدمون الادوات البسيطه
ربما يعني يتمكنوا من الوصول الى
الاشخاص
العالقين في هذا المبنى ايضا هناك اخر
مقابل لهذا المبلغ رشا انه تم انقاذ سيده
اربعينيه منذ قليل في احد المباني في
كهرمان مرعش وكانت على قيد الحياه والان
هناك جهود بعد سماع اصوات احياء تحت هذا
المبنى الذي نشاهده معك على الهواء مباشره
اسمع سماع بعض الاصوات لاحياء ربما تحاول
فرق الانقاذ مساعدتهم لاخراجهم من تحت
الانقاض
غسان
ساعود الى غسان نعم اسمعك غسان تفضل
طبعا هناك مشكله
كهرمان
مرعش اليوم افضل من الامس واضح انهم
استطاعوا اضاءه بعض الاماكن لذا نشاهد
الصوره بوضوح في كهرمان مرعش اثناء خروج
بعض
الاشخاص من تحت الانقاذ ونحن نشاهد هذه
صور مباشره مراسل العربيه الزميل غسان
اشار الى ان فرق الانقاذ قالت له انه
صدرت اصوات وانه تم التوجه قرب هذه
الاصوات واستخدام الالات الثقيله لرفع
الاحجار ثم بدا استخدام الالات البسيطه
لمحاوله الوصول الى هؤلاء
لانقاذهم باعتبار ان هناك مؤشرات انهم ما
زالوا على قيد الحياه
ومن اديمان موفد العربيه محمود شكر مرحبا
بك محمود كيف تبدو الصوره لديك
الصوره هنا في هذه المباشر هي من نوع اخر
هي قصه الموت النازحين السوريين الذين
انتقلوا من حمص وادلب والذي قيا الى هذه
المنطقه كانوا في المخيمات منذ سنوات
الماضيه ثم انتقلوا الى الشقق التي
استاجروها واشتروها ولكن منذ اربعه ايام
عادوا الى المخيمات وانما الى هذه الزوايا
تحت هذه المؤسسات والمحلات التجاريه قطع
من النايلون علها ترضع عنهم قساوه البرد
وعلها ايضا
تاتي اليهم بشيء من الدفء المساله هنا في
هذا ليس المطالبه بتامين الطعام او الشراب
انما المساله هي فقط والاصوات ترتفع انه
في البنايه التي على جنبنا لا زالت طفله
منذ اربعه ايام
متاكد انها قد توفيت هو يطالب فقط ان ياتي
الدفاع المدني يقول انا اريد ان اذهب بها
فقط الى المقبره
نريد ان احفظ لها هذه
احفظ لها هذه العادات والتقاليد الدينيه
بان اقوم بحمل اقله ابنتي بعد هذه الايام
الى المقبره معي مباشره الى القيم
الان جاهدين هذه
البعث من
هذه
على جوانب في الزوايا يؤمنون ما استطاعوا
وما يحملونه
محمود الصوت ليس واضح محمود
ساعود اليك بالطبع ولكن اذهب ايضا من جديد
الى زميلي غسان في كهرمان مرعش كرمان
مرعشان كانت بؤره او مركز رئيسي لهذا
الزلزال وبالتالي كانت العين عليها كبيره
باعتبار انها اكثر المناطق تضررا كيف تبدو
الصوره خلال او بعد ثلاثه ايام من وقوع
هذا الزلزال نحن في اليوم الرابع له
نعم بالفعل رشا الوضع ماساوي في كهرمان
مرعش كما قلت هي مركز الزلزال والوضع سيء
جدا
مباني عديده وهناك يعني
في هذه المدينه هناك احياء بالكاملة سوريه
في شارع يضم عشرات المباني المنهاره الان
يطلبون من
عمال الانقاذ وقف الاليات
للحظات صمت ربما في الجهه الاخرى تم الطلب
من الجهه الاخرى رشا من المنقذين ان
يوقفوا الاليات ويطفئوها لانها في المنطقه
الثانيه او
ابلغونا ايضا
على قيد الحياه تحت تلك القرض في المبنى
الثاني يعني حسب
عناصر الانقاذ حتى هذه اللحظه رشا فانه في
مبنيين هناك ثمانيه اشخاص
حتى هذه اللحظه
يعملون بشكل متواصل متواصل
بشكل لا ادري ان كنت تسمعيني رشا ام لا
لكن على اي حال هناك تمنه ثمانيه اشخاص
اكيد المعلومه التي تتحدث عنها طلب من فرق
الانقاذ ان تتوقف وان يسود التوقف لماذا
هل سيتم اخراج بعض الناجين الان
اللحظات رشا يطلب الصمت حتى يستمعوا الى
اصوات العالقين وبالتالي يحددون النقطه
يعني النقطه التي يكونوا موجودين فيها
بالضبط ومن ثم
الحفر باتجاههم من تلك النقطه لذلك
فرق الانقاذ وقف كل العمليات البحث واطفاء
الاليات الثقيله حتى يتاكدوا من اين يصدر
هذا الصوت وبالتالي يباشرون العمل طبعا
هذه اليه يتم استخدامها وايضا يستعينون
بالاجهزه الحديثه والكاميرات الحراريه
يستخدمون الكلاب المدربه لكن فقط اود
الاشاره بان هذا
المبدا
اشخاص على قيد الحياه والمبنى الاخر مقابل
والمبنى الاخر مقابل ثلاثه اشخاص اذا هناك
ثمانيه اشخاص على قيد الحياه حسب فرق
الانقاذ هنا في مبنيين حيث نقف وما زالوا
هم يواصلون اعمالهم في محاوله منهم للوصول
الى هؤلاء
انقاذهم
يعني
ادراكهم قبل ان يدركم لا سمح الله الموت
في ظل هذه الظروف الصعبه نتحدث عن اربعه
ايام تحت الانقاض لا ماء ولا غذاء طبعا
الجو بارد درجات حراره متدنيه جدا وهذا
يعني
يعني مشكله تضاف على المشاكل التي يواجهها
بدات في الحفر والرفع من جديد
نعم بالفعل رشا بدات عمليات
الحفر بالاليات الثقيله يحاولون يعني
ازاله ما يمكن ازالته من هذه الانقاض
ليتمكنوا من الوصول الى
العالقين في هذا المبنى كما فهمنا من
عناصر الانقاذ رشا بان الخمسه العالقين في
هذا المبنى موجودين في غرفه داخليه يعني
ربما هناك مسافه عده امتار حتى يتمكن
الوصول اليها لكنهم يحاولون يعني ايجاد
ثغره بين هذه الانقاض للوصول الى العناقين
تحت هذه الانقاض طبعا هذا المشهد
رشا يمتد على طول هذا الشارع الذي انا اقف
فيه
اليات بالعشرات تعمل وتواصل عملها في
محاوله للوصول الى ناجينا في هذه الكارثه
التي حلت على البلاد طبعا
بلديه كهرمان مرعش قال بان ان البنيه
التحتيه دمرت تماما في مدينه كهرمان مرعش
وبالتالي يعني هي مدينه منكوبه
الوضع صعب جدا
هم بحاجه ايضا
لدعم واسناد سواء كان في ما يتعلق
بالمساعدات الانسانيه والاغاثيه وايضا
فيما يتعلق بعمال الاغاثه والانقاذ لذلك
اليوم
من معلومات مهمه منذ قليل قلت ان هذا
المبنى سمع اصوات من المتوقع ان يكون خمسه
اشخاص تحت انقاذ هذا المبنى وانه تم
التوقف قليلا للتاكد من هذه الاصوات
والمنطقه القريبه منها حتى يتم استعاده
اعمال الحفر
نعم صحيح رشاه هذا المبنى الذي ترونه الان
على الشاشه يوجد فيه حسب عمل الانقاذ
من بينهم نعرف عدد الاطفال او لا يعرفون
عدد الاطفال وفي مبنى مقابل لهذا المبنى
الذي نقف امامه هناك ايضا ثلاثه اشخاص على
قيد الحياه اذا هناك ثمانيه اشخاص في على
قيد الحياه بحسب عمال الانقاذ تستمر
عمليات البحث وتستمر عمليات رفع هذه
يتمكنوا من الوصول الى
يعني لا ادري ما الذي يعني لفت انتباهه في
هذه النقطه بالضبط لكنه يعني يحاول الوصول
لشيء ما او ربما يحاول
يعني
هكذا كانت استطلاع او الوضع الطبقات
الاسمنتيه
نعم رشا تتكرر الصوره حينما تكون هناك
اصوات تصدر من بعض المناطق نشاهد رجال
الانقاذ يقتربون منها ويحاولون اضاءه
المكان
للنظر بداخله للتاكد من الاصوات لمحاوله
انتشال بعض العالقين كما قال زميلي غسان
هم لديهم معلومات ان هناك اشخاص ما زالوا
على قيد الحياه في هذه البنايه غسان يقول
انه بعض المصادر اشارت اليه الى ان خمسه
اشخاص صنع اصواتهم بالاضافه الى مبنى اخر
مجاور لهذا المبنى فيه ثلاثه اشخاص ايضا
وبالتالي هذه صور للعربيه مع الزميل غسان
موفد العربيه من منطقه كهرمان مرعش وهي
منطقه مهمه جدا في هذه الجهود باعتبار
انها كانت مركزا للزلزال الذي وقع في جنوب
تركيا وشمال سوريا وكانت درجته قد تجاوزت
7.8 وبالتالي هي من المناطق التي وبشده
هذه صور العربيه من كهرمان مرعش وسننتقل
ايضا الى ايدمان موفد العربيه محمود شكري
كان محمود يتحدث ايضا عن احوال المنكوبين
في هذه المناطق وكيف هناك محاوله
لاحتوائهم او اسعافهم وتقديم العون لهم
اليك محمود
نعم نحن كما اشرت معك في بدايه هذا
المباشر اذا الى اننا نتحدث عن النزوح
السوري في هذه المنطقه وهذه الصور
المباشره لهذه العائلات التي جمعت ما
امكنها من اهرامات وايضا ومن بطانيات وهي
اتخذت اما جوانب الطرقات كما الان في هذه
الخيمه التي انشات على عشرين وجمعت عدد
طفله صغيره نائمه على ما يبدو محمود
نعم ساذهب الى الصوره هذه الشاب الصغير
والعائله باكملها
بجانبها متقدمه في السن سالت عنها قالوا
بعد الزلزال يعني هي لا تعلم ماذا جرى لها
وحالتها يرثى لها كما اشرت معك هنالك
نوعين من عمليات الارقام التي تجري يظهر
ويبدو ان الجل الاهتمام الاكبر يذهب الى
الاتراك في بدايه المنطقه الثانيه وهنالك
مراكز كبيره لهم للماوى وايضا بالجانب
المقرب الاخر ان النازحين السوريين
يطالبون بمزيد من الاهتمامات تكون اكثر
لهم ان كان من خيم او من منازل ما تسمى
بمنازل المركبه او يكون لهم تقديمات على
قاعده الطعام الجاهز كما يقدم ايضا في
باقي المدينه
معك الى ان هنالك قصص انسانيه يعني منذ
حوالي ثلاث ساعات كنا في هذا الحي وكانت
وكانت العائلات وايضا رب عائله هو يطالب
كما اشرت بان يكون عنده الحل الاساسي او
المطلب الاساسي من فرق الانقاذ ان تاتي
وتقوم برفع الارقات لاخراج جثه طفلته التي
هي من
ذهبنا التي تظهر معنا في الصوره يبدو انها
تتالم
بطبيعه الحال الالم هي ليس على المسلمه هي
على كل حالتها صعبه جدا وايضا كان البعض
يسال عن تقديمات لها سريعه وهذه المساله
لا تقتصر عليها انما انما هي على الكل
يعني اذا اذا اذا ذهبنا ايضا بهذه الصوره
هنا الى هذه المراه مع عائلتها وهذه البنت
الصغيره هنا التي تفترش الارض نحن نتحدث
يعني على جانب الطريق على بطانيه من ثلاثه
سم العازل بيننا وبين الشارع هو ايضا هذه
البطانيه هم ركبوا هذه المدافئ التي تعمل
على الخشب امنوا التدفئه اقل ولكنهم
يريدون ان يتطوروا
بحالتهم ان ينتقلوا اقلها الى خيام او
تكون لهم
نرجع الى من كانوا يقفوا حولك في الكاميرا
ولنترك هذه الطفله تنام في امان يعني اذا
كان يعني في هذه اللحظات لا نملك شيء سوى
ان نتركها تنام في سلام نعم
ولكن الذي لفتني بالوصول الى هذه المنطقه
واللقاء مع الاطفال حتى الصغار كان الحديث
معهم الى اننا انه ليش بدنا نموت ما هو
الموتش طبيعي ما نحن لحم موت فخلينا هلا
نموت لحتى هذا الطفل لا اعلم هو اسمه
عدنان اخذته الكاميرا ما بعرف عدنان شو
الوضع
شو الوضع يا عدنان
وين البيت
هو كان يقول يعني قبل الهواء مشاهد مؤلمه
محزنه
مبكيه ايضا يعني واضح انه متعب ولا يريد
الحديث
نعم هو لا يريد الحديث ولكن قبل الهواء
كان الاطفال او الصغار هم يقولون في
المعاناه التي عاشوها نعم يكفي المعاناه
التي عاشوها خلال
الايام الماضيه ساعود اليك زميلي محمود
لرصد الصوره من حولك في خدمتنا الاخباريه
المتلاحقه الزميل محمود شكر منفذ العربيه
الى ايدي مان شكرا لك
اعود مره اخرى الى زميلي غسان لمتابعه
كهرمان مرعش حيث مركز هذا الزلزال العنيف
والصوره تنقل لنا جهود الانقاذ التي ما
زالت متواصله في هذه المنطقه حول عدد من
المباني ونشاهد الاليات الثقيله مستمره في
العمل اليك غسان
نعم بالفعل رشا كما تشاهدين الاليات
الثقيله عملها
وتحاول يعني
سحب هذه الانقاض شيئا في شيئا لعلهم
يتمكنون من
الدخول او الوصول الى
اشخاص العالقين الخمسه كما ذكرنا سابقا
وهو ما ينطبق ايضا على
مباني الاخرى المنهاره لفرق الانقاذ التي
تواصل اعمالها حتى هذه اللحظه وهذه الساعه
طبعا رشا درجات الحراره متدنيه جدا هناك
حاله يعني برد قارس في هذه المنطقه وهو
يعني من الامور التي
تشكل خطر كبير على العالقين تحت الانقاض
تعلمين انهم يعني في اوضاع ماساويه تحت
الانقاذ منذ اربعه ايام وبالتالي هذا يشكل
خطر على حياتهم الان هم
ي على نقطه معينه ربما يعني توصلوا لشيء
في هذه
النقطه في هذا المبنى لا شيء واضح حتى
الان
على اي حال كما كنت اقول ان العمليات
متواصله في هذا الشارع الذي اقف فيه هناك
عشرات المباني منهاره في هذا الشارع ناهيك
عن مباني اخرى ايضا في
هذه المناطق
كهرمان مرعش الى اين تمت انتقال الاهالي
يعني رشا تم انشاء
مخيمات طوارئ يتم نقلهم الى اماكن امنه
بطبيعه الحال يتم اخراجهم من كهرمان مرعش
وفي محيط المدينه ونحن قادم
ين يعني ناس قد اقاموا خيم باضافه الى
الخيام التي انشات في اطراف المدينه ايضا
يتم نقلهم الى مراكز ايواء اكثر امانا
تقوم السلطات بتولي هؤلاء ونقلهم الى
مناطق اخرى اكثر امانا
تواصل السلطات جهودها في عمليات النقل
طبعا هناك طائرات عسكريه وهناك الخطوط
الجويه التركيه وايضا هناك طائرات رئاسيه
تقوم بعمليات النقل
ومن يستطيع رشا ان يذهب بسيارته الخاصه او
لديه اقارب ياتون الى هنا وينقلوهم يمكن
ذلك ايضا الطرقات يعني مفتوحه والسير على
الطرقات ممكن في هذه المناطق والخروج من
هذه المناطق الجنوبيه تحديدا التي تعرضت
للزلزال والذهاب الى مناطق اخرى المسافات
صحيحه انها طويله لكن عمليات الاغاثه
متواصله والمساعدات في كل مكان رشاينما
توجهت واينما
ذهبت ممكن ان تشاهدي
هبات شعبيه ومساعدات انسانيه سواء كانت
الرسميه او من منظمات المجتمع المدني
وايضا من الشعب الذي هب لمساعده المواطنين
هنا هناك من يقومون بانشاء خيام لتوزيع
الملابس على المتضررين ايضا هناك من يقوم
بطهي الطعام وتوزيعه على
عمال الانقاذ وعلى المتضررين هناك حاله من
التكاتف هناك يعني عشرات الالاف من الشباب
والشبان جاءوا للتطوع في
هذه المناطق المنكوبه الحديث عن
هناك اكثر من 110 الاف شخص يعملون في
عمليات
الانقاذ والاغاثه رشا ايضا الى اضافه الى
المتطوعين الذين يصلون تباعا طيله الايام
الماضيه الى هذه المناطق لتقديم
باعتبار انك اشرت الى
هناك مبنى الذي يتم العمل عليه من قبل
رجال الانقاذ الان لاخراج الاصوات التي تم
السماع اليها غسان ستبقى معنا في هذه
التغطيه مع الزميله ليال حيث تتواصل معك
ومع بقيه زملاء على الارض لمتابعه الاحداث
لحظه بلحظه اليك
[موسيقى]